on the right hand side we have a bunch
of expressions that are just ratios of
different information given in these two
diagrams and then over here on the left
we have the sign taken of angle mkj
cosine of angle mkj and tangent of angle
mkj and angle
mkj
is this angle right over here same thing
as theta so these two angles these two
angles have the same
measure we see that right over there and
what we want to do is figure out which
of these expressions are equivalent to
which of these expressions right over
here and so i encourage you to pause the
video and try to work this through on
your own
so assuming you've had a go at it so
let's try to work this out and when you
look at this diagram it looks like the
intention here on the left is this
evokes the the unit circle definition of
trig functions because this is really a
this is a this is a unit circle right
over here and this evokes kind of the
sohcahtoa definition because it's we're
just kind of in a plain vanilla right
triangle and so just to remind ourselves
let's just remind ourselves of sohcahtoa
because we have a feeling it might be
useful so sine is opposite over
hypotenuse cosine is adjacent over
adjacent over hypotenuse and tangent
is opposite over adjacent so we can
refer to this and we can also refer to
remind ourselves of the unit circle
definition of trig functions that the
cosine of an angle is the x-coordinate
and that the sine of of where this this
of where this ray intersects the unit
circle and the sine of this angle is
going to be the y coordinate and what
we'll see through this video is that
they're they're actually the unit circle
definition is just an extension of
sohcahtoa
so let's look first at x
over 1.
so we have
x x is the x coordinate that's also the
length of this side right over here
relative to this angle theta that is the
adjacent side so x is equal to the
adjacent side what is one well this is a
unit circle one is the length of the
radius which for this right triangle is
also the hypotenuse so if we apply the
sohcahtoa definition
x over one is adjacent over hypotenuse
adjacent
over hypotenuse adjacent over hypotenuse
that's cosine so that's going to be
this is equal to cosine of theta
but theta is the same thing as angle mkj
they have the same measure so cosine of
angle mkj is equal to cosine of theta
which is equal to
x
over
1. now let's move over to y over 1. well
y is going to be the length of
this side
right over here
y is going to be
why let me do this in the blue y is
going to be this length relative to
angle theta that is the opposite side
that is the opposite side
now which trig function is opposite over
hypotenuse opposite over hypotenuse
that's sine of theta
sine of theta so sine of angle mkj is
the same thing as sine
of theta we see that they have the same
measure and now we see that's the same
thing as y over 1.
now for both of these i use the
sohcahtoa definition but we could have
also used the unit circle definition x
over 1 that's the same thing that's the
same thing as x and the unit circle
definition says well this x this point
the x coordinate of where this i guess
you could say the terminal side of this
angle this ray right over here
intersects the unit circle that by
definition by the unit circle definition
is
the cosine of this angle it x is equal
to the cosine of this angle and the unit
circle definition the y coordinate is
equal to
the sine of this angle we could have
written this we could have written this
as instead of x comma y we could have
written this as cosine of theta
sine
theta just like that
but let's keep going
now we have x over y we have adjacent
over
we have adjacent over opposite so this
is equal to adjacent
over
opposite
tangent is opposite over adjacent not
adjacent over opposite so this is the
reciprocal of tangent so this right over
here if we had to this is equal to one
over tangent of theta and we later learn
about cotangent and all of that which is
essentially this but it's not one of our
choices so we can rule this one out
but then we have y over x well this this
is looking good this is
y is opposite
opposite
x is adjacent relative to angle theta
adjacent so this is the tangent of theta
this is equal to tangent of theta so
tangent of angle mkj is the same thing
as tangent
of theta which is equal which is equal
to y over x
now let's look at j over k
so j over k now we're moving over to
this triangle j over k so relative to
this angle because this is the angle
that we care about j is the length of
the adjacent side and k
is the length of the opposite side
of the opposite side so this is adjacent
over opposite
so this is equal to adjacent
tangent is opposite over adjacent not
adjacent over opposite so once again
this is 1 this is the reciprocal of the
tangent function not one of the choices
right over here so we can rule that one
out
now k over j well now this is opposite
over adjacent opposite over adjacent
that is equal to tangent of theta this
is equal to tangent
of theta or tangent of angle mkj so this
is equal to k
over j
now we have m over j
m over j hypotenuse
over adjacent side this of course
this of course is equal to the
hypotenuse
hypotenuse over adjacent well if it was
adjacent over our hypotenuse we'd be
dealing with cosine but this is the
reciprocal of that so this is actually 1
over the cosine of theta not one of our
choices not one of our choices here so
i'll just rule that one out right over
there but then we have its reciprocal
reciprocal j over m that's adjacent over
hypotenuse adjacent over hypotenuse is
cosine so this is equal to cosine of
theta or cosine sine of angle mkj so we
could write it down so this is
equivalent to j
over m
and then one last one k over m well
that's opposite over hypotenuse opposite
over hypotenuse that's going to be sine
of theta
so this right over here is equal to sine
of theta which is the same thing as sine
of angle mkj which is the same thing as
all of these expressions so this is
equal to k over m
and we are done